so Steph in terms of you know anarchy
and extreme measures as an actress what
are some of the extreme measures you
would take for a role in terms of
obtaining information getting in front
of a casting director what would you do
what would you not do today I think
research is really important I think
just understanding like the history of a
character that their entire backstory
and where they've come from what drives
them to do what they they set out to do
sort of things so I think doing a lot of
research instead of putting yourself in
the mind of the character so you
wouldn't do something that like let's
say obtain someone's information you
know you hear about someone like using a
pizza and putting their head shot and
things like that was there anything that
you've done that maybe slightly crossed
the line but it got to a role in terms
of getting in front of the right person
so I think the most extreme thing I've
done is sort of shot an audition in an
environment like outside sort of in for
costume and really gone for but I don't
think I never put my candidates of looks
or anything like that right okay that's
fair so you want to be you feel that an
actor should play by the rules and there
are any rules I'm not really sure and
maybe the rules are meant to be Bert
I haven't yet okay well enjoy the film
tonight thank you appreciate you thank
you